à lancé dans le Loire etcher Denis Retif
cultive 70 hectares de céréales il a
choisi la production de semences plus
valorisante et alterne maïs semence et
blé hybride seulement voilà en octobre
2014 on lui impose une troisème variété
de culture on apprend au mois d'octobre
que on est obligé de faire trois
cultures donc pour moi il est un petit
peu difficile de me retourner et de
faire une troisième culture du fait que
c'est déjà signé c'est déjà
contractualisé j'ai déjà mes surfaces de
de maïs mais surface de de blé et donc
le raisonnement il se fait sur une année
pour nous il se fait pas sur un mois et
on nous pom pas une réglementation qui
va arriver au mois d'octobre pour une
application au mois d'octobre parce que
on est déjà au mois d'octobre on est
déjà en train de semer à quelques
kilomètres au-delà Valière les grandes
Sylvain Boiron élève 150 chèvres et 70
moutons lui aussi a découvert une
nouvelle réglementation qui le laisse
perplexe car ces bêtes pissent près
d'une forêt qui n'est peut-être plus une
forêt pour l'administration pour
l'administration il y a plusieurs types
de bois il y a les groupes d'arbres les
bosquiers les forêts les bordures de
bois enfin on sait pas trop ce que c'est
les gens qui ont réfléchi à ça ils ont
été beaucoup beaucoup à l'école mais pas
beaucoup dans la forêt et et je pense
enfin c'est complètement indéfinissable
ce qu'il y a dans les textes on narrive
pas on narrive pas à s'y retrouver quoi
avec des calculs d'équivalence de bois
d'arbres isolés enfin c'est c'est
illisible pour un paysan c'est illisible
et ce respect impossible d'une
réglementation tardive aura des
conséquences tout autant pour le
séréalier que pour l'éleveur l'incidence
c'est que ces surfaces là vont pas
compter ça veut dire qu'il faudra dans
les surfaces où je fais de la culture
par ailleurs qui représente que la
moitié de mon exploitation et bien il
faudra que dans ces endroits là je
réimplante des trucs que j'ai déjà dans
les autres surfaces de mon exploitation
c'est complètement débile et tout ça
c'est pas pour avoir de l'argent en plus
c'est juste pour garder la même argent
qu'on nous donnait avant pour sa part le
syndicat FDSEA dénonce cette nouvelle
règle du jeu et met en garde contre ces
lourdes conséquences le danger j'ai
devant nous il y a une partie du
territoire si il y a pas des solutions
apportées pour gommer les impacts
négatifs des exploitations il ils auront
la responsabilité de l'abandon de
l'agriculture sur plusieurs territoires
de ce département une certitude il y a
d'un côté des pratiques des choix
stratégique d'exploitation et de l'autre
des règles fluctuantes qui se
multiplient et même si la nature a du et
a aussi horreur du
tropelin